[girl screams]
[phone rings]
- HELLO?
- HI.
WITH WHOM AM I SPEAKING?
- JOHNNY DILLBY.
- JOHNNY.
- UH-HUH?
- I THINK YOU KNOW WHO I AM.
I'M HELEN.
I WAS IN YOUR STORE
THE OTHER DAY,
AND I GAVE YOU A REQUEST FOR
A CERTAIN
PEPPERIDGE FARM COOKIE.
FOR THE MACADAMIA CRUNCH.
DID YOU GET THAT FOR ME?
- WHEN DID--WHEN
DID I SEE YOU?
- WAIT, I HAVE
TO BLOW MY NOSE.
I HAVE A COLD.
EXCUSE ME.
[blowing nose]
I'M SORRY, JOHNNY.
NATURE CALLS.
ALL RIGHT, UM, IT WAS
SOMETIME LAST WEEK.
I ORDERED THE COOKIE.
YOU'RE THE HANDSOME
ONE, AREN'T YOU?
- UH, WELL, HOPEFULLY.
[laughs]
- YEAH, HOW OLD
ARE YOU, DARLING?
- 27.
THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT.
I'M THAT VERY ATTRACTIVE
OLDER WOMAN THAT FLIRTS WITH
YOU ALL THE TIME.
YOU KNOW WHO I AM?
- NOT RIGHT OFF.
[laughs]
- YOU KNOW, I--LISTEN,
HERE'S WHAT I WANT, JOHNNY.
- OKAY.
- I WANT YOU TO DELIVER THE
COOKIES TO ME PERSONALLY.
AND I WANT YOU TO JUST, YOU
KNOW--JUST BETWEEN YOU AND
ME AND THE DEVIL, I'D LIKE
TO BE SPRAYED IN THE MUG.
SO I WANT TO
TAKE THE COOKIES.
I WANT TO CRUNCH
THEM UP ALL OVER ME,
AND I WANT YOU TO
LICK THEM OFF OF ME.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
- WHAT?
[laughs]
- YOU HEARD ME, JOHNNY.
- YOU'RE KIDDING ME, RIGHT?
- NO, I'M NOT KIDDING YOU.
I WANT YOU TO GRAB A
JAR OF THAT MAN GRAVY,
AND I WANT IT ALL
OVER MY BEHIND.
- WHAT?
- MY HUSBAND DOESN'T
SERVICE ME ANYMORE, JOHNNY.
DO YOU UNDERSTAND
WHAT I'M SAYING?
AND YOU'RE A VERY
ATTRACTIVE MAN.
I COME IN THERE
ALL THE TIME.
I ASKED FOR THE COOKIES.
REMEMBER?
I ORDERED THE COOKIES.
AND YOU SAID YOU
WOULD GET THEM FOR ME.
AND NOW WHAT I WANT IS I
WANT YOU TO DELIVER THEM TO
ME PERSONALLY.
OKAY?
AND I'LL MAKE YOU FEEL
VERY GOOD, JOHNNY.
ARE YOU MARRIED?
- MAYBE YOU NEED TO
COME BY AND TALK TO ME.
- YOU WANT ME TO
COME BY IN PERSON?
I'D BE VERY HAPPY TO.
- WHY DON'T YOU COME
BY AND TALK TO ME.
- YOU SURE?
- COME BY AND TALK TO ME.
- I'LL COME BY TODAY IF
I KNOW YOU'LL BE THERE.
- I'LL BE HERE FOR
THE REST OF THE DAY.
- WILL YOU TELL ME IF
YOU'RE MARRIED OR NOT?
- WE'LL DISCUSS THAT
WHEN YOU GET HERE.
- NO, I WANT TO KNOW IF IT'S
WORTH MY TIME OR NOT, JOHNNY.
- WELL THAT'S WHAT I'M GONNA
TELL YOU WHEN YOU GET HERE.
- REALLY?
YOU'RE VERY--I FIND YOU
VERY SEXY, WITH THAT VOICE.
ALL RIGHT, BECAUSE--NOW LET
ME TELL YOU SOMETHING THAT
YOU DON'T KNOW.
I HAVE FALSE TEETH.
WHEN I TAKE THEM OUT, I
COULD MAKE YOU FEEL SO GOOD,
YOU WON'T KNOW WHAT HIT YOU.
I'LL HAVE A COOKIE
AND YOU ALL AT ONCE.
AND THEN YOU COULD
HAVE MY COOKIES.
ALL RIGHT?
- COME AND TALK TO ME.
- I'M GONNA COME
TALK TO YOU, JOHNNY.
I'LL BE OVER THERE--IS
THIS STILL YOU?
- YEAH.
- I KNOW, YOU'RE SEXY
AS ALL GET OUT, JOHNNY.
THAT'S WHY I ASKED FOR YOU.
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
YOU WANT ME TO COME DOWN?
- COME DOWN.
- ALL RIGHT, I'LL
BE THERE ANY MINUTE.
- ALL RIGHT.
- ALL RIGHT, DARLING.
GOOD-BYE.